مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه النافذه
الانسانيه الخاصه نناقش فيها استمرار قوات
الاحتلال باستهداف القطاع الصحي حتى اصبح
مئات الاف الاشخاص في الشمال تحديدا
محرومين من الخدمات الطبيه اخر هذه
الاعتداءات اعلان الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني
ان سلطات الاحتلال اعتقلت عددا من كوادره
من داخل مركز اسعاف جباليا ودمرت مركبات
الاسعاف هذا الملف سنناقشه مع ضيفنا من
مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير البلح اسماعيل
الثوابت المدير العام للمكتب الاعلامي
الحكومي في غزه ولكن قبل ذلك نود ان نذكر
بحصي الشهداء جراء الحرب الاسرائيليه على
قطاع غزه عدد الشهداء ارتفع الى اكثر من
20 ال شهيد بحسب وزاره الصحه في غزه
المكتب الاعلامي الحكومي في غزه قال ان من
بين
من بين الشهداء 8000 طفل
و62 امراه بينما عدد الجرحى وصل الى
و320 منذ السابع من اكتوبر تشرين الاول
الماضي اذا الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني قال
ان قوات الاحتلال ما تزال تعتقل ثمانيه من
طواقمه الطبيه في مركز اسعاف جباليه وكان
الهلال الاحمر قد قال ان ثمانيه الثمان
100000 شخص فلسطيني في المناطق الشماليه
لقطاع غزه محرومون من الخدمات الطبيه اما
منظمه الصحه العالميه فحذر من ازدهار
الامراض المعديه بفعل الافتقار الى
المرافق الصحيه والنظافه وانهيار النظام
الصحي وقالت المنظمه ان مليون و400 ال شخص
يقيمون في ملاجئ مكتظه وتشهد غزه بالفعل
معدلات مرتفعه من الامراض المعديه وتم
الابلاغ عن اكثر من 100 ح ال000 حاله
اسهال منذ منتصف اكتوبر نصفها لاطفال دون
سن الخامسه واشارت المنظمه الى وجود اكثر
من
150 1000 حاله من حالات عدوى الجهاز
التنفسي العلوي وفي غزه اليوم في المتوسط
لا يوجد سوى مكان للا للاستحمام واحد لكل
4500 شخص ومرحاض واحد لكل
220 شخصا نعود الى ضيفنا من مستشفى شهداء
الاقصا في دير البلح اسماعيلي ثوابته
المدير العام للمكتب الاعلامي الحكومي في
غزه اذا هذه الارقام التي ذكرناها تظهر
بشكل او باخر سيد اسماعيل ان الوضع الصحي
فعلا منهار بالكامل والخدمات الصحيه في
الشمال تحديدا اصبحت مع
معدومه نعم بكل تاكيد اخي حسن يعني منذ
بدء هذه الحرب وكانت الحرب على المستشفيات
والحرب على القطاع الصحي معلنه من اول يوم
من هذه الحرب العدوانيه حيث ان جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قضى تماما على القطاع
الصحي في المحافظات الشماليه لقطاع غزه
سواء كان في محافظه غزه او محافظه شمال
غزه تمكن من تقريبا اقتحام جميع
المستشفيات واستهداف جميع المستشفيات
وايضا تفجير جميع الاجهزه الطبيه داخل هذه
المستشفيات وبالتالي نستطيع القول اليوم
ان شمال قطاع غزه شمال وادي غزه محافظه
غزه محافظه الشمال لا يوجد بها مستشفيات
تستطيع ان يعني تقدم الخدمه للمواطن
الفلسطيني وربما الجميع شاهد حتى الكوادر
الطبيه نتحدث عن اكثر من 100 حاله اعتقال
من بين الاطباء والكوادر الطبيه وايضا على
راس هؤلاء المعتقلين مدير عام مجمع الشفاء
الطبي الدكتور محمد ابو سلميه وكذلك مدير
مستشفى كمال عدوان الدكتور احمد الكحلوت
وبالامس ايضا تم استهداف الدكتور منير
البرش وكيل وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه
وجميعهم في محافظه شمال غزه وهذا يؤكد ان
القطاع الصحي هو تحت دائره الاستهداف
وبالتالي الوضع الصحي وضع كارثي جدا في
قطاع غزه طيب امام الوضع الكارثي فيما
يتعلق بالمرافق الصحيه التي تم تدميرها
والتي خرجت عن الخدمه والتي استهدفت
طواقمها وايضا موضوع الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني الذي استهدف واستهدفت ايضا
سيارات الاسعاف يضاف الى كل ذلك انتشار
الاوبئه الان المعلومات تتحدث عن انتشار
لامراض معديه في ظل عدم وجود مرافق صحيه
حتى لها علاقه ا كانت ا كانان المرحاض او
حتى اماكن الاستحمام وغير ذلك كيف يتم
التعامل مع هذا الواقع
المزري نعم نعم يعني هذه هذا الواقع الذي
يعكسه النازحون هنا في في قطاع غزه الذين
نزحوا من منازلهم الى مراكز الايواء او
الى منازل غير منازلهم وبالتالي اصبح هناك
اكتظاظ كبير جدا نتحدث عن مليون و800 ال
فلسطيني نزحوا من منازلهم وتوجهوا الى
اماكن غير لائقه ب السكن او ان تكون كماو
نحن في الحكومه الفلسطينيه قمنا باحصاء
اكثر من
355000 حاله اصابه بامراض معديه سواء كان
داخل مراكز النزوح والايواء
او حتى خارج مراكز النزح والوا وهذه
الامراض معظمها امراض معديه متعلقه
بالامراض الجلديه او الامراض ذات العلاقه
بالجهاز التنفسي او الجهاز الهضمي او غير
ذلك من الامراض وبالتالي هناك نتحدث عن
اكثر من ثلث مليون انسان في قطاع غزه الان
هو مصاب بامراض معديه نتيجه حاله النزوح
ونتيجه حاله يعني العدوان الاسرائيلي
والحرب الاجراميه الوحشيه التي ما زال
يمارسها هذا الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وبالتالي
نحن نتحدث عن عن وضع كارثه في قطاع غزه
ايضا في ظل منع الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
لادخال الادويه وادخال العلاجات ومنع
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ايضا لادخال الوقود
من اجل تشغيل هذه المستشفيات نتحدث عن خ
35 مستشفى في قطاع غزه الاحتلال دمر واوقف
عن الخدمه 23 مستشفى و55 مركز صحي ايضا
توقفت عن الخدمه نتحدث عن
10038 مؤسسه صحيه استهدفها جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وبالتالي كل هذه الارقام
الخياليه والصدمه تؤكد ان القطاع الصحي هو
في بؤره الاستهداف طيب موضوع موضوع
الامراض يعني هذا الامر خطير جدا خصوصا
عندما يفتقر الجهاز الطبي اكان للادويه او
اللقاحات او حتى ل مستوصفات او مستشفيات
هذا الموضوع بالتحديد ما مدى خطورته حاليا
في ظل هذا الواقع انت تتحدث عن امراض
تنفسيه عن امراض معويه وكلها على ما يبدو
امراض معديه ستنتشر بشكل
كبير بكل تاكيد اخي حسن فيما يتعلق حتى في
هذا الموضوع المنظمات الدوليه مقصره بشكل
كبير جدا نحن اطلقنا مئات المناشدات ذات
العلاقه في موضوع ادخال الادويه الى قطاع
غزه وادخال العلاجات وادخال اللقاحات ولكن
للاسف الشديد جميع المنظمات الدوليه بلا
استثناء تضع في اذنها اذن من طين واذن من
عجين ولا تستمع نهائيا لكل هذه المناشدات
اطلقنا مناشدات لمنظمه الصحه العالميه
اطلقنا مناشدات للامم المتحده ذاتها
اطلقنا مناشدات ل لمنظمه الصليب الاحمر
لاوتش لكل المنظمات الدوليه والامم وطلبنا
بضروره معالجه هذا الواقع الصحي الخطير
وقلنا لهم ان الواقع الصحي يتعرض الى
الاستهداف بشكل مباشر وهذا الاستهداف كان
له انعكاس سلبي على حياه النازحين وعلى
حياه المواطنين هنا في قطاع غزه نتحدث
اكثر من 2 مليون و400 او حوالي 2 مليون
400 ال انسان في قطاع غزه يتعرضوا الى
الاصابه بهذه الاوبئه وبهذه الامراض خاصه
ايضا في ظل انتشار جثامين الشهداء الذين
ما زالوا نتحدث عن اكثر من
6000 اكثر من
6500 جثمان من جثامين الشهداء ما زالوا
تحت الانقاض حتى هذه اللحظه ولم تتمكن
الطواقم الحكوميه ايضا من انتشالهم وهذا
كله يسبب بشكل كبير جدا في انتشار الاوبئه
وتتحمل مش ذلك جميع المنظمات الدوليه
والمجتمع الدولي ثواتي المدير العام
للمكتب الاعلامي الحكومي في h